questo è un pallet un pallet è una
piattaforma di stoccaggio che serva allo
stoccaggio e al trasporto delle merci
generalmente fatta di legno riciclato o
comunque di un legno povero e la sua
caratteristica è la solidità anche
questo è un pallet però assomiglia molto
di più una libreria e qui ringrazio
simone perché io avrei detto il sito
simone e cito il chimico la quasi e che
nel 1700 diceva niente si crea niente si
distrugge e tutto si trasforma e
potrebbe essere proprio il mio mantra
quotidiano perché io passo le mie
giornate a trasformare oggetti ma cos'è
che mi fa vedere una libreria in un
pallet
cos'è che mi qual è il processo mentale
che mi fa passare dal punto a al punto b
sicuramente l'inizio di tutto è il
momento in cui io inizio a guardare un
oggetto e smetto di vederlo in casa
siamo pieni di immobili di vestiti né
suppellettili che ci portiamo dietro
perché li abbiamo ereditati perché ce li
hanno regalati insomma per mille ragioni
e fanno parte della nostra vita
quotidiana quindi noi passiamo
continuamente e non li guardiamo li
vediamo fino al giorno in cui aprendo
una porta il mobile allora potete
notarlo possiamo notarlo perché pensiamo
però questo mobile fichissimo non lavoro
sottovalutato e in quel caso
continueremo a notarlo e ci continuerà a
piacere tantissimo ma esiste anche il
momento in cui entriamo guardiamo il
mobile e ve lo dico perché a me
purtroppo è successo con un tavolino di
mia nonna e pensate è orribile cioè come
ho fatto ad averlo in casa fino adesso
quindi quello è il momento è la
scintilla che fa partire tutto il
processo deciso di cambiarlo ma come
da dove prende l'ispirazione cioè
laddove prendo le idee
la risposta è ovunque
cioè noi siamo circondati da trame forme
colori poi oggi con internet con i figli
siamo bombardati continuamente di
immagini ecco se noi riusciamo ad
estrapolare un segmento di un'immagine
un piccolo dettaglio e lo ingrandiamo
riusciamo a trovare un ispirazione
questa per esempio è la colonna è una
colonna del sito archeologico di oplonti
dove io sono stata tantissime volte
perché ogni volta mi innamoro di un
pezzo nuovo immaginate questa questa
queste geometrie ingrandito enormemente
messe su uno stencil poggiate su un
pavimento con gli stessi identici colori
perché sono dei toni perfetti ottenete
un restore non un ristorante ormai sono
partita con simone un risultato
meraviglioso una buona tecnica è quella
di creare un archivio che può essere una
scatola può essere un cassetto nel mio
caso dopo tutti questi anni è il
sottotetto nel quale non si riesce quasi
più ad entrare dove raccogliere ogni
cosa che ci piace ogni cosa che ci può
far ritornare alla mente quel dettaglio
perché certo nel momento in cui diciamo
io voglio cambiare il mobile non è detto
che poi in quell'esatto momento avremo
l'idea perfetta però se noi abbiamo
questa specie di archivio perché abbiamo
notato abbiamo guardato e qui ritorniamo
al punto iniziale vuol dire che nel
momento del bisogno ce ne ricorderemo e
uscirà fuori
io per esempio ho la fortuna di
viaggiare tanto e ogni volta da ogni
viaggio mi porto dietro delle
impressioni che non sono le immagini del
telefonino oppure della macchina
fotografica no saltava delle delle
impressioni per esempio io adesso ho
fatto un viaggio in giappone e mi ero
innamorata della loro estetica
ecco quell'estetica diciamo orientale
ha continuato a venire fuori per
tantissimo tempo dopo il viaggio quindi
ogni volta mi porto dietro qualcosa
adesso sempre più spesso però ll dell
altra possibilità mi chiamo e mi
innamoro dei materiali cioè mi succede
di trovare qualcosa per esempio dei
tappi di plastica e pensare in questo
caso ne avevo tantissima v un bustone
gigantesco di tappi di classica e
pensare qualcosa ne devo fare e ed è
venuta fuori una lampada allo stesso
modo in realtà il pallet è partito dalla
piccola grata dorata che c'era su un
avevo vista da un ferramenta mi ero
innamorata ma pensata una va beh questa
è la devo assolutamente utilizzare e
così è stato
a questo punto all oggetto ho trovato
l'ispirazione ho deciso come farlo non
mi resta che eseguire ecco nel fai da te
purtroppo o per fortuna la
l'improvvisazione non esiste o perlomeno
esiste molto poco perché se decidete di
fare una lampada e non avete nessuna
idea di come fare dei collegamenti
elettrici può essere pericoloso
allo stesso modo se decidete di
dipingere con della tinta lavabile su
della formica
il risultato è perfetto per i primi
cinque minuti poi al primo colpo di
spugna abbia tutto questo perché perché
i due materiali sono incompatibili per
questa ragione quando ho iniziato a fare
il programma pensionline io nascevo
decoratrice quindi sapevo tanto di
pennelli pitture tutto quello che aveva
a che fare con il mondo della
decorazione ma ben poco di seghe
martelli e tutto il resto
e quindi mi hanno dovuto affiancare ai
agli attrezzisti di cinecittà che sono
dei geni assoluti sono in grado di
riprodurre qualsiasi cosa cioè poi
arrivata una mattina di roma oggi vorrei
un mobile rocco cotti in cinque minuti
dopo cinque minuti no ma in due giorni
un mobile rococò perfetto quindi ho
lavorato tantissimo tempo con loro
e diciamo tutta la parte tecnica la devo
proprio a loro è fatta praticamente ho
guardato ho trovato l'ispirazione ho le
conoscenze tecniche per fare il mio mio
progetto per realizzarlo
manca un elemento un elemento che
secondo me non è meno importante ed è la
pazienza
il fai da te richiede tantissima
pazienza spesso mi dicono eh ma tu sai
fare sempre tutto oppure ma io non
riesco a fare niente le due affermazioni
non sono vere nessuno sa fare tutto
nessuno io ci sono state delle volte che
ho dovuto rinunciare a dei progetti
perché non ne veniva a capo per avuto
delle difficoltà tecniche che non sono
riuscita a sormontare e ci sono state
altre volte in cui mi sono dovuta
accontentare di un risultato però tutte
le volte sempre in qualsiasi progetto
sia quelli andati a buon fine che quelli
invece che purtroppo pochi per fortuna
si sono interrotti
io ho insistito insistito poi continua a
pensare pensare a trovare una soluzione
attuare un alta ci vuole tempo
ci vuole pazienza e ci vuole
perseveranza tanta alla fine di tutto
questo processo di tutte queste di tutti
questi passaggi nasce un oggetto nuovo
un oggetto che è stato ri decorato da
voi con me come questo vassoio che è
stato decorato con della della resina e
che era un vassoio banale ed è diventato
un vassoio per me è speciale oppure una
vecchia scatola magari della nonna che
ha assunto un valore valore nuovo che si
adatta meglio all'arredamento della casa
che non è andato ad aumentare i rifiuti
respinti scarica che non è un dettaglio
devo dire ma soprattutto in tutti e due
i casi che mi ha dato e ci ha dato una
enorme soddisfazione personale
perché la verità vera del fai da te è
questa
come tutti i lavori manuali il fai da te
da una soddisfazione pazzesca cioè alla
fine il risultato non dice qua ho fatto
io è venuto benissimo l'ho fatto io e
quindi quello secondo me è un aspetto
molto molto interessante io nella mia
vita ho dato spazio alla manualità prima
come decoratrice poi come conduttrice
televisiva perché comunque mi occupavo
di un programma di bricolage e adesso
sul web ed alla fine di ognuna di queste
esperienze è nata quella successiva
quindi io penso che non solo per gli
oggetti ma anche per le persone ci possa
essere una seconda una terza è anche una
quarta possibilità come questo piccolo
pezzo di carta sul quale io inizialmente
ho preso i primi appunti del del toc
poi ho disegnato sopra le potenziali
chiatti per un cliente e adesso è
diventato un gioco per bambini
sì